um we now have reached a horrible
milestone in the United States where
guns are the leading cause of child
deaths for those under 18. the New York
Times had a very good piece on this a
couple of days ago and if you look at
leading causes of death for children
ages 1 through 18. if you're looking on
the screen you see this green line which
is guns which has now surpassed motor
vehicle crashes at 19 percent of deaths
for children age 1 to 18 it is guns
followed by motor vehicle crashes cancer
drug overdoses which has increased and
Suffocation has decreased putting it
into fifth position into fifth position
this Century okay since the year 2000 as
you can see on the screen if you're
looking guns have have risen as the
cause of death from 10 percent of kids
age 1 to 18 to 19 percent
nearly five in a hundred thousand die
each year kids
uh these are stunning numbers most of
the deaths are homicides
many of the victims are black and mostly
boys there are also suicides the
suicides are mostly white and mostly
boys there are relatively few of what
would be called accidental deaths we
take issue with the term accidental
typically you're talking about
negligence actually but very few are
what are often called accidental deaths
we hear about oh a dad was cleaning his
gun and shot his daughter dead we do see
those stories but those are actually
relatively few
this is a uniquely American problem and
in order to start thinking about
Solutions we have to really understand
the problem this is not a global
epidemic if you look globally the most
common causes of death for children are
infectious diseases 45
disproportionately in the developing
world uh 15 uh pneumonia and respiratory
disease 12
preterm birth and neonatal disorders ten
percent diarrheal categorized disease
nine percent congenital defects now as a
math issue it is true I know people are
going to write to me and say this so I
will be very upfront with you if you
reduce one thing simply by comparison
another thing is going to go up so in
the U.S
we have certainly reduced some of these
elements as causes of death right
diarrheal disease death in the United
States and kids is a lot rarer than in
other parts of the country so if you
drop that then other stuff will go up
like gun deaths but even in the rest of
the developed world where there isn't
much diarrheal child death you do not
see gun death numbers like we see in the
United States so what are the
differences between the Us and other
countries well we have one of the
highest rates of gun ownership is it
that alone no but that's a factor one of
the highest rates of gun ownership so
there are guns around kids we have a
lack of strict gun control laws in most
States
we have a culture that glorifies
violence and uh exposes even kids I mean
you know we're talking 14 15 16 17 year
olds completely exposed and affected by
that very culture that glorifies
violence sees guns as a way to solve
problems High rate of poverty
High rate of income inequality both of
which have been studied in connection to
guns as a public health issue and lack
of access to Mental Health Resources now
of course I have no interest
in ignoring any of these aspects the
right loves to say it's just mental
health meanwhile they don't want to fund
Mental Health mental health is certainly
a factor but availability of guns
widespread nature of guns that's a
factor as well there are clear steps we
can take I've outlined so many of them
so many times before no one step will
solve this problem no one step will
solve the problem and we always hear
after a shooting well you know your idea
of limiting clip capacity wouldn't have
prevented this particular shooting
I don't know anyone who claims any one
thing when you have a problem that's
based on six to eight things there's no
one thing that will solve that problem
but we have to work on all of these
things and quite frankly the numbers
speak from the for themselves unique to
the United States if you want to let me
put it this way
if you want to find other countries with
a gun violence uh problem affecting kids
to the degree that we have in the United
States
I'm not going to name the countries you
will find countries that none of these
right-wingers would say are in any way
equivalent to the United States
so take a look
we're going to link to the study in the
New York Times we're going to continue
talking about all of it but we have
plenty of ideas
but we have a right wing that is
unwilling to actually try any of them
make sure you're subscribed to our
YouTube channel youtube.com slash the
David Pacman show